[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la terre promise au travail forcé de
parcours malheureusement classique et
tragique des boliviens qui quittent leur
pays pour venir travailler ici à sao
paulo on les trouve plutôt dans la
banlieue de la ville travaillant 15
heures par jour dans les ateliers de
couture clandestins pour nous pondre des
semis chic et bon marché que nous
connaissons bien en europe et à part
quelques exceptions le bolivien illustre
ce célèbre et tragique également
proverbe brésilien le pauvre mange de la
viande quand ils se mordent la langue
après le miracle le mirage brésilien
c'est un sujet de michael burdell
[Musique]
sao paulo ville tentaculaire fascinante
et écrasante dans cette jungle urbaine
les rivières de béton déversent des
flots de voitures
bienvenue à semblent pas pour les
intimes un enchevêtrement de béton et
d'acier qui s'étend sur plus de 100 km
du nord au sud
dans cette fourmilière géante première
mégalopole d'amérique du sud la
population atteint 20 millions
d'habitants parmi eux trois cent
cinquante mille fourmis ouvrières les
boliviens les laissés pour compte de
l'explosion économique les parents
pauvres de l'immigration
pour se faire entendre les boliviens ne
lésine pas sur les moyens pas de
carnaval comme à rio mais une
manifestation haute en couleurs dans le
centre historique de la ville
aujourd'hui tous les immigrés
sud-américains se sont rassemblées pour
scander leur ras-le-bol
soyez tous les bienvenus et commençons
ici notre cinquième marche des immigrés
pour que nous ayons tous les mêmes
droits le droit de vote le droit de vote
tout de suite
[Musique]
lille a bien pâli 6
non non non derrière ce mur
[Musique]
nombre
d'émigrés invisible au brésil
nous aussi nous avons des droits que
nous voulons conquérir
nous sommes des travailleurs et nous
voulons obtenir il est
perdu dans la foule béatrice a débarqué
de bolivie il y a six mois après quinze
jours de bus et de galère cette mère
célibataire est arrivé clandestinement à
sao paulo avec sous le bras maïza sa
fille de 2 ans aujourd'hui encore elle
ne possède aucun papier
et bolivie les gens disent que la vie au
brésil est facile qu'on gagne facilement
de l'argent ce n'est pas vrai
le travail est dur ici au début je
voulais rentrer je pleurais je voulais
rentrer chez moi béatrice est venue
manifester avec sa patronne chimène
elle-même bolivienne depuis 11 ans
qu'elle est au brésil la situation a peu
changé et les discriminations sont
quotidiennes
ouvert pour les brésiliens les boliviens
sont des ivrognes
les boliviens sont des noms
on entend toujours des blagues sur nous
ça fait rire
ils disent même qu'ils ont aidé à
[Musique]
sao paulo la majorité des boliviens
travaillent dans des ateliers de couture
clandestins aux conditions sociales et
sanitaires désastreuses
ou quand la terre promise se transforme
en purgatoire
[Musique]
quartiers de paris en plein coeur de la
ville dans ses rues des milliers de
boutiques de confection majoritairement
détenus par des sud coréens ici c'est
l'équivalent du sentier parisien mais
derrière les façades le revers de la
médaille c'est au fond d'une ruelle dans
l'un des nombreux ateliers de couture
clandestins que l'on retrouve béatrice
c'est dans cette petite manufacture de
fortune qu'elle a trouvé un emploi il ya
cinq mois
au milieu du bruit des machines à coudre
des enfants ceux des ouvrières attention
ne va pas de couper maïza la fille de
béatrice ne quitte jamais les jupons de
sa mère
tous les matins dès 7h30 béatrice
s'assoit derrière sa machine elle ne la
quittera plus jusqu'à 22h30 15 heures de
travail quotidien pour un salaire de 500
real par mois trois fois le salaire
minimum olivia
mon rêve c'est d'avoir une petite maison
en bolivie que je pourrais les gars ma
fille et que je puisse lui payer des
études
faire des économies pour l'envoyer à
l'université
je ne veux pas que ma fille fasse le
même travail que moi je veux qu'elle est
un bon métier
qu'elles soient diplômés avocate ou
quelque chose comme ça
à quelques mètres à peine séparée par
une simple cloisons un minuscule réduit
de 5 mètres carrés où dormait hatrize et
maïza
ici nous sommes dans ma chambre elle est
petite mais c'est ma chance c'est un peu
le bazar avec ma fille
c'est son échographie quand elle avait 6
mois
c'est pour elle que je travaille c'est
pour elle que je suis ici
c'est pour elle que j'ai vécu des
moments difficiles
quand je suis triste et que je pleure
cl ma grande consolation elle me prend
dans ses bras et me fais des bisous et
avec ses bras je sens une tendresse que
je n'ai jamais ressenti auparavant
[Musique]
chimène la patronne de béatrice est une
ancienne petite main ouvrière exploité
pendant des années elle a fini par
obtenir la gestion de cet instrument
elle n'a pas vraiment le choix alors
elle reproduit ce schéma d esclavage
moderne pour répondre à nos questions
elle décide de s'installer à son ancien
poste de travail histoire laissant la
place
de travailler maintenant
doucement je vais les disputes et moi
les petites filles je vais à gronder
[Rires]
ici ce ne sont pas des esclaves
les esclaves sont enchaînés les esclaves
obéissent aux ordres
ils ont choisi de travailler ici fort
kg
et puis là-bas en bolivie le salaire
minimum c'est entre 100 et 200 real
pokal et on travaille la mine et moi
les 500 real que chimène verse tous les
mois à béatrice sont légèrement
inférieurs au smic brésilien mais son
temps de travail dépasse les 70 heures
hebdomadaires dans un pays où la durée
légale du travail est fixée à 44 eur
[Musique]
la situation des mots livia n'est
heureusement pas toujours aussi
dramatique
si 80 % d'entre eux sont clandestins
d'autres plus instruits sont également
venus profiter du boom économique
brésilien nous avons rendez vous dans un
petit cabinet de dentiste du centre
historique de sao paulo
bonjour comment ça va
hugo était dentiste en bolivie comme de
nombreux confrères il a fait le choix
d'émigrer il travaille aujourd'hui dans
quatre cabinets différents un business
très lucratif qui peut lui rapporter
jusqu'à 4000 $ par mois
via sopo l'aude une course permanente je
suis obligé de courir d'un cabinet un
jour suis dans un coin le lendemain dans
l'autre et ainsi de suite
ici c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
financièrement on peut gagner jusqu'à
trois ou quatre fois plus
les avant de réussir au brésil hugo à
collectionner les problèmes comme de
nombreux immigrés logement nourriture
titre de séjour alors aujourd'hui son
temps libre il utilise pour aider ses
compatriotes dans ces sacs des vêtements
pour la maison des immigrants un centre
social qui aident les étrangers
les jours père mario
qu'est ce que tu nous apportant
quelques affaires pour nos camarades
immigrés
merci beaucoup
ne rien classe
le problème quand je suis arrivé au
brésil c'était la langue la seule chose
que je savais dire c'était coca cola et
pendant deux trois jours je n'ai mangé
et bu que ça
la première difficulté c'était la longue
et la deuxième c'était d'avoir mon titre
de séjour
un titre de séjour un rêve pour tous les
immigrés bolivien c'est le cas de dina
jeune femme de 28 ans arrivé il y a deux
ans mais depuis la naissance de sa fille
sur le sol brésilien les autorités ont
décidé de lui accorder le fameux sésame
je crois que quand se seraient
légalisées je pourrai commencer à
travailler dans dans quelque chose comme
ça arrive même pas à l'imaginer
tu n'imagines pas encore non
tu pourrais travailler avec un permis de
travail tu dois l'exigé et avec ce père
me tuera le droit au 13e mois et athée
congés payés
une fois son titre de séjour en poche la
carte de travail et délivré
automatiquement pour dina c'est la fin
de deux années de galère clandestine
nous sommes dimanche ici au brésil c'est
le jour du seigneur unique journée de
repos hebdomadaire c'est ici place
cantuta que les boliviens ont l'habitude
de se retrouver
on y déguste de link à colas et du thé
aux feuilles de coca hugo y emmène
fréquemment ce n'est liée à sa fiancée
ça c'est une partie de l'abolir j'ai le
mal du pays je viens i5 et
il ya plein de boliviens de nourriture
bolivienne on ressent plus de chaleur
humaine
[Musique]
un peu plus loin béatriz elle aussi est
venu profiter de son seul jour de congé
avec maïza
coucou maïs à pompon
je viens ici pour ne pas être triste et
ne pas penser à ma mère qui me manquent
et toute la famille qui est en bolivie
c'est pour cela que l'on est ici pour
que ma fille se change les idées qu'elle
s'amuse un peu
un petit bisou à sao paulo les boliviens
sont les premières victimes de
l'explosion du marché du travail
actuellement une grande enseigne de
prêt-à-porter espagnol est sous le coup
d'une enquête accusé d'avoir employé des
migrants dans des conditions proches de
celles de l'esclavagé
un problème que les autorités souhaitent
régler au plus vite le travail forcé
doit absolument disparaître du cv de la
sixième économie mondiale
[Musique]
on a maintenant rendez vous au circolo
italiano l'une des plus autour de sao
paulo on va rencontrer frédéric donnent
tous les français il est chef
d'entreprise fait de la coop c'est un
converti de la première heure il est
arrivé ici il ya 25 ans il va nous
raconter la montée en puissance du pays
et de la ville il va nous parler du
fameux miracle brésilien même si vous
allez voir qu'il aime pas trop se perdre
bonjour prague aujourd'hui tort alors
c'est devenu le fantasme à un petit peu
d'une europe en crise on parle beaucoup
du miracle brésilien est ce qu'il existe
réellement et à quoi il ressemble il ya
un gros changement le côté miracle
n'aime pas beaucoup parce que c'est un
côté facile
le brésil marc bien le brésil et et
redécouvert il a été dans les années 70
80 mais je crois qu'il n'est pas bien
compris et que vu de l'europe ça y est
il faut être au brésil je crois pas que
ce soit si simple que ça c'est une
république qui a moins de 120 ans qui a
eu plusieurs périodes de dictature
militaire donc c'est un pays très jeune
fait par des immigrants donc
l'apprentissage de la république de la
démocratie et tout ça il ya eu un
décalage est aujourd'hui c'est en train
d'arriver le brésil va bien aujourd'hui
il a des bons fondamentaux
mais il a surtout des brésiliens je
crois que la plus grande source du
brésil c'est les brésiliens la magie
c'est ça c'est ça on va changer le terme
peut-être pas le miracle mais comment ça
se vit tous les jours cette situation au
brésil cette énergie dégagée à vivre au
brésil c'est super parce que ça fait moi
ça fait 25 ans que j'y suis j'ai décidé
d'immigrés
c'est un choix personnel donc je suis
venu en 85 et
avec ma femme sans enfants d'abord à rio
puis après à sao paulo et c'est un pays
où les gens
vous demandent pas d'où vous venez mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comment
vous voulez contribuer donc cette cette
approche cette énergie et en même temps
cette grande tolérance parce qu'on ne
sait pas un pays complètement fait c'est
un pays très tolérant pour vivre au
quotidien c'est fantastique donc vous
avez assisté en fait à l'évolution et la
montée en puissance du pays ah oui
absolument ça s'est passé ça c'est a été
rapide non on a eu plusieurs phases je
pense que le l'apprendre la transition
démocratique c'est très bien fait c'est
un désavantage du brésil par rapport aux
autres bric c'est démocratiquement
parlant c'est un pays qui fonctionne
fernando riquet a mis les grandes bases
lula a très bien continuer et à donner
un élan on a eu un bonus démographique
fantastique c'est à dire que on est
passé de six gamins par famille à deux
gamins par famille donc moins d'enfants
à éduquer et moins d'enfants rentrant
dans la société donc il est normal
qu'ils rentrent au milieu de la société
et non en bas un pays relativement
encore fermées donc pas sujet aux aléas
des crises au souk preuves et compagnie
cette conjoncture de choses puis au
final on finit par dire du et brésiliens
tout ça ça a fini par aider à faire que
le pays aujourd'hui et les gens n'ont
jamais cessé d'y croire je pense que une
constante c'est que le brésilien votre
toujours la bouteille à moitié pleine ou
de l'amour est évident si on avait des
leçons à prendre au brésilien s'est
peut-être celle là alors nous a sans
aucun doute je pense la tolérance et
l'optimiste
comment sont accueillis les immigrés ici
bien bien parce que c'est c'est naturel
c'est spontané c'est rapide on vous
demande un peu votre histoire le
brésilien sait intéresse le brésil est
un curieux et est gentil et
naturellement ouvert et puis après on
passe rapidement bon qu'est ce que tu
veux faire et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
ensemble
donc c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
un processus historique et naturel c'est
le coeur de la société la mentalité
brésilien n'y a pas de race brésilien
vous pouvez brésilien il peut être
besoin bien c'est un esprit président et
c'est ça qui fait sens fort physiquement
d'ailleurs n'a pas d'oeil a pas de race
physique il ya un esprit un état
d'esprit loisirs et sao paulo est un
condensé de tous ses états brésiliens
qui ont émigré à un moment où à un autre
faire vous manque la france la france
est beau c'est culturellement
fantastique mais
l'énergie que je reçois des français au
bout d'un certain moment peut être
irritantes par rapport au brésilien qui
lui avait beaucoup moins et beaucoup
plus sourire beaucoup plus optimiste et
au fond ce qui compte c'est d'être
heureux au quotidien donc être heureux
en amérique latine au brésil
particulièrement aujourd'hui à la limite
c'est
sur le papier plus difficile parce que
vous avez beaucoup moins de garanties
d'atouts et de sécurité le dans le
quotidien plus facile c'est quand même
pas normal merci frédéric merci victor